[Musik]
hey ZDF heute live am Tag 5 für die
Menschen in der Ukraine im Krieg es gab
heute zwar Gespräche zwischen zwei
verhandlungsgruppen von Kiew und Moskau
an der Grenze zu Belarus aber die
scheinbar zunächst ohne Ergebnis da geht
es wohl in eine zweite Runde und
währenddessen sind die Menschen in der
Ukraine nach wie vor entschlossen und
wir können das alle bei Social Media
sehen im Widerstand von ganz normalen
Menschen teilweise also zivilen Menschen
die sich gegen russische Panzer gegen
russische soldatenstellen und wollen für
ihre Freiheit und Demokratie kämpfen das
sind Bilder die gehen um die Welt
aktuell bei Social Media teilweise sind
es auch Frauen junge alte die selbst mit
der Waffe üben oder Molotowcocktails
basteln Ukraine will zeigen wir geben
nicht auf und der Krieg in der Ukraine
der verändert auch unsere Welt und ein
Teil davon also wie wir hier in
Deutschland uns künftig verteidigen
wollen das soll heute unser Thema sein
mit dem wir mit euch gemeinsam
diskutieren ansprechen wollen denn
gestern da ist auch was er denkwürdiges
passiert Beifall im Bundestag im
Deutschen Bundestag für die Ankündigung
von Kanzler Scholz die deutschen
Verteidigungsausgaben künftig zu erhöhen
und vor dem Krieg war das mit Sicherheit
vor dem Krieg in der Ukraine keine
Entscheidung die Beifall ausgelöst hat
aber jetzt sei es so eine Zeitenwende
und alles hätte sich geändert also
Scholz hat da was verkündet dass die
Verteidigungsausgaben steigen sollen
außerdem 100 Milliarden Euro
Sonderzahlungen sondern Aufrüstung für
die Bundeswehr und auch das es gibt
wieder eine Diskussion über die
Wehrpflicht in Deutschland und wir haben
euch gefragt vorher in unserem Community
Tab was ihr darüber denkt und haben
ziemlich viele Meinungen dazu schon
bekommen ich will ein paar davon
rausgreifen greifen sabba de Plum
schrieb keine Wehrpflicht militärische
Berufe müssen attraktiver werden also
auch das ein Argument oder Viktor
schrieb ich bin gegen eine Wehrpflicht
jeder sollte selbst entscheiden können
und Frie aufrüsten findet er gefährlich
aber auch das hier Dennis 38r die
Wehrpflicht ist aus meiner Sicht ein
singender Faktor zum Wiederaufbau der
Landesverteidigung und um die Chance zu
haben junge Männer langfristig zu
rekrutieren ich glaube da gibt es viel
drüber zu sprechen eure Kommentare und
Fragen dazu jederzeit bei uns im Chat
oder per Mail stellt sie uns gerne ich
versuche so viele wie möglich davon
mitzunehmen und wir können jetzt über
dieses Thema diskutieren mit der
FDP-Politikerin Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann sie ist die Vorsitzende im
Verteidigungsausschuss und mit Patrick
Sensburg erst von der CDU Präsident des
Reservistenverbandes der Bundeswehr
schönen guten Abend guten Abend guten
Abend
schön dass sie beide bei uns sind es ist
direkt die Frage die ich an Sie stellen
möchte wir sind jetzt mit der
Wehrpflicht nämlich schon eingestiegen
das ist eine Debatte die ist bei uns
also auch schon im Chat hochgekocht und
da würde ich sie gerne Fragen Herr
Sensburg sie fordern es soll wieder eine
Wehrpflicht geben warum also ich habe
schon 2011 damals im Deutschen Bundestag
gegen die Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht
gestimmt weil ich gesagt habe wir können
nicht davon ausgehen dass die
Friedensdividende von der wir damals
gehofft haben dass sie lange halten wird
wirklich ewig bleibt es wird wieder
gegebenenfalls auch Bedrohung für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland geben und
deswegen brauchen wir die Wehrpflicht
weil wir zum einen die aufwuchsfähigkeit
der Bundeswehr brauchen weil wir aber
auch zu Durchhaltefähigkeit in
Konflikten bei Bedrohung nicht nur auf
die aktiven Soldaten zählen können
sondern weil wir dann auf Reservisten
und Reservisten die aus der wehrpflichte
herauskommen zählen müssen um dann diese
Aufgaben die auf uns zukommen
gemeinschaftlich zu schultern mit
aktiven Truppe und den Reservisten und
Reservisten und man muss ja auch eins
wissen wir können keine ganz ganz große
aktive Truppe aufstellen wir wollen
nicht wieder 500 oder 6000 Soldaten in
Deutschland haben wenn wir also weniger
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in der aktiven
Truppe haben dann brauchen wir die
Wehrpflicht um im Falle eines Falles
auch aufwuchsfähig zu sein
Frau Zimmermann sie sind die Vorsitzende
des Verteidigungsausschusses was sagen
sie dazu
also ich sehe das anders das ist jetzt
nicht wirklich erstaunlich
zuallererst mal ist die Wehrpflicht in
der Tat ausgesetzt worden ich
abgeschafft worden sie würde aber heute
geltend für Frauen und Männer weil das
gerade angeklungen ist bei dem Kommentar
des Herrn der vorhin was geschrieben hat
also es betreffen Männer und Frauen aber
losgelöst davon sehe ich das deswegen
anders weil wir haben 180 182.000
Soldaten und Soldaten und das Problem
ist dass die Bundeswehr eben nicht so
ausgestattet ist wie eine moderne Armee
ausgestattet sein müsste und wenn man
sie attraktiv gestaltet wenn sie gut
ausgerüstet ist dann ist sie auch
attraktiv für junge Männer und Frauen zu
Armee zu kommen das ist momentan eben
nur begrenzt der Fall denn wenn Sie
heute ein Hubschrauber kriegen wollen
oder bei der Marine sein wollen und die
Schiffe nicht fahren oder die Zug
entsprechende flugmaterial nicht
funktioniert und sie gar ihre
Flugstunden nicht mal einhalten können
dann ist es eben nicht mehr attraktiv
man verlieren viele Menschen auch sie
haben es angesprochen die Bundeswehr ist
also auch schlecht ausgerüstet stand
jetzt aber glauben Sie Geld alleine
würde dann reichen muss man nicht
irgendwie auch noch den Job also
attraktiver machen und geht es also
wirklich am Ende dann ohne die
Wehrpflicht
also ich persönlich bin der Meinung es
geht ohne die Wehrpflicht dass wir haben
und wollen und das war ja auch der Grund
dass das Aussetzen das ist überhaupt
keine lehrgerechtigkeit in Deutschland
mehr gab also 2010 Ali weiß ich auch von
der Generation meiner Kinder die nur
noch ein paar Prozent derer die in der
Klasse waren so Wehrpflicht eingezogen
worden oder sind wehrpflichtig gewesen
die anderen haben sich ich sag mal
hatten alle Rücken obwohl sie
anschließend wieder Fußball gespielt
haben das interessierte aber gar keinen
das heißt die Ausmusterung war relativ
schnell getan und das war natürlich mit
ein Grund warum das befeuert wurde das
ist keine Wehrgerechtigkeit mehr gab
heute ist die Armee eine hightech-armee
die ist eben nicht mehr so wie das der
ein oder andere in meiner Generation
noch träumerisch sagt das hat uns alles
nicht geschadet das war klasse sondern
sie ist eine Hightech Armee und insofern
brauchen wir eine exzellente Ausbildung
die auch nicht so einfach mal man in
einer kurzen Zeit abreißen kann deswegen
glaube ich wenn wir eine attraktive
Armee haben wenn wir Gerät haben was
junge Leute auch erleben wollen an was
sie auch arbeiten wollen dann bin ich
sicher dass wir auch genügend Männer und
Frauen finden die bereit sind diesen
nicht ganz ungewöhnlich oder nicht ganz
gewöhnlichen Beruf auch zu erreichen in
den letzten Jahren ist die Zahl der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten immer weniger
geworden schauen wir mal kurz zusammen
drauf bevor wir weiter darüber sprechen
die Truppenstärke der Bundeswehr gegen
einen letzten 30 Jahren deutlich zurück
Anfang der 1990er Jahre waren im Schnitt
fast eine halbe Million Soldatinnen und
Soldaten im Dienst Anfang 2022 wenn es
nur noch knapp 183.000 auch das
Aussetzen der Wehrpflicht ab Juli 2011
war eine Zäsur inzwischen wächst die
Truppe wieder leicht
Herr Sensburg ihrer Meinung nach wie
viele Soldaten und Soldaten bräuchte die
Bundeswehr um eben verteidigungsfähig
handlungsfähig zu sein also ich gebe
erstmal Frau Strack Zimmermann absolut
recht wir brauchen eine attraktive
Truppe wir brauchen ausreichend
Finanzmittel um auch die notwendigen
Geräte die Waffensysteme Waffen
anzuschaffen auszubilden und
dementsprechend auch einen attraktiven
besonderen Arbeitsplatz zu liefern der
dann auch unsere Soldatin und Soldaten
wenn sie in den Einsatz gehen sicher
macht das hat die Priorität wir brauchen
aber auch das sehen wir gerade an der
Grafik Soldatinnen und Soldaten da wird
es nicht wieder in die alte Zeit
zurückgehen können mit fast einer halben
Millionen Soldaten in Deutschland
deswegen brauchen wir um durchhaltefähig
zu sein die Wehrpflicht um im Falle
eines Falles dann auch genügend Männer
und Frauen zu haben die im Zweifel auch
für den Heimatschutz für die Sicherheit
des Landes einstehen können und das ist
auch eine Wahrheit wir werden ohne
Reserve ohne Wehrpflicht diese Zahlen
nicht leisten können und das sehen wir
jetzt gerade in der Ukraine wir haben
auf der einen Seite natürlich eine
moderne hochtechnisierte Bundeswehr wo
wir viel zu verbessern haben wir
brauchen aber auch gleichzeitig
Soldatinnen und Soldaten für Aufgaben
wieder Objektsicherung der Sicherung
kritischer Infrastruktur und deswegen
ohne diese große Zahl dann auch von
boots on the ground von Männern und
Frauen die unterschiedlichste Aufgaben
wahrnehmen können geht es nicht nur mit
Hightech ist kein Krieg zu gewinnen das
sehen wir gerade in der Ukraine
Frau streckt Zimmermann gibt es da schon
ganz konkret ja antworten Sie gerne
darauf und ich würde von Ihnen aber
gerne auch noch wissen ob es ganz
konkret schon Pläne gibt wie man das
jetzt attraktiver gestalten möchte
also ich würde gerne noch mal darauf
reagieren weil es ist ja nicht nur eine
Frage der Männer und Frauen die um die
es geht sondern es ist auch eine Frage
der Logistik ist auch eine Frage der
Unterbringung die wirklich ist ja nicht
ausgesetzt worden und dann sind alle zu
Hause geblieben sondern in diesem
Augenblick wurden Kasernen geschlossen
ich kann vor meiner Heimatstadt
Düsseldorf sagen wir hatten zwei große
Kasernen die eine ist schon lange weg
dort ist ein Neubaugebiet die andere ist
im Begriff zu verschwinden dort wird
aufgebaut werden das heißt wir haben
viele Städte und Gemeinden wir hatten
mal Kasernen die jetzt heute gar nicht
mehr da sind und der Grund und Boden ist
an die Kommunen gefallen für Wohnungsbau
dann haben die Kasernen die heute viel
zu eng sind denn wenn Sie heute Männer
und Frauen für den Dienst gewinnen
wollen dann schaffen sie das nicht mehr
dass da zwölf Mann oder 12 Frauen in
einer Stube sind sondern dass der
Anspruch auch ein anderer ist das heißt
sie brauchen auf der Fläche gesehen die
brauchen mehr Fläche für die gleiche
Zahl Anzahl der Soldaten Soldaten und
dann kommt dazu das Soldaten und
Soldaten
mit ihren ihren soll bekommen und das
heißt wir haben jetzt schon sehr hohe
Ausgaben relativ gesehen rein für
Personal und deswegen wenn jetzt sich
nicht was ändert und jetzt kommt er die
gute Nachricht wenn auch der Grund
tragisch ist wenn sich nichts ändert
wenn man nicht mehr Geld in die Hand
nimmt dann frisst sozusagen das Geld der
Etat das Personal die Personalkosten auf
ohne das auch nur ein Hubschrauber mehr
eingekauft worden ist deswegen halte ich
diese Debatte bei allem Respekt auch vor
der Diskussion für an dieser Stelle auch
völlig
gutes wird aus dem Hut gezogen aber ich
halte sie für nicht wirklich hilfreich
was wir jetzt schaffen müssen jetzt
komme ich auf ihre Frage zurück wie
Attraktivität aussehen muss wenn ich
heute als junge Frau zur Bundeswehr
gehen wollte und ich würde sagen ich
würde gerne zur Luftwaffe gehen wo auch
immer jetzt dort eingesetzt aber das
Material funktioniert nicht ich kann das
nicht lernen ich kann das nicht umsetzen
oder ich möchte zum her würde gerne
Fachbereiche machen die eben nicht
funktionieren dann ist das nicht
attraktiv das heißt wenn junge Männer
und junge Frauen ihren Beruf bei der
Bundeswehr leisten wollen dann wollen
sie zu einem in einem bestimmten
zeitstreitkraft und da muss alles eben
auch so sein dass sie dort ausgebildet
werden dass sie einsatzfähig sind das
sind schnellsten und umgehend
einsatzfähig sind und das ist bei einer
professionellen Gruppe mit freiwilligen
halte ich das für abgesichert wirklich
für ausgesprochen
sinnstiftend und die Zahl der 500.000
Soldaten 1990 wir hatten in kalten Krieg
es gab die NATO aber es gab vor allen
Dingen den Warschauer Pakt und insofern
halte ich das für heute auch die
Diskussion jetzt entbrennt darüber halte
ich für
erstaunlich dass sie kommt aber ich
halte sie für unnötig lassen Sie uns
jetzt mal aufs Geld schauen der
Bundeswehr Etat der ist zwar in den
letzten Jahren ein wenig gestiegen aber
eben nur langsam wir schauen kurz
zusammen drauf
inzwischen wächst auch der
Verteidigungshaushalt wieder 2014 als
die NATO das 2% Ziel beschloss lag er
bei knapp 32 Milliarden Euro seitdem
steigt der von Jahr zu Jahr im
vergangenen Jahr auf fast 47 Milliarden
es gibt Fragen auch bei uns im Stream
eine würde ich gerne jetzt auch an Frau
Streik Zimmermann noch mal direkt
stellen wir diskutieren aber auch gleich
weiter Hans Müller bei Facebook fragt
die 100 Milliarden die jetzt also
zusätzlich also als sofort quasi ja
sofort Geld kommen sollen sind die dann
zusätzlich zu den regulären 50
Milliarden wer Etat also 150 insgesamt
fragt Hans Müller
ja also es geht darum dass der
Bundeskanzler und Finanzminister ja
gestern klargestellt hat es ist ein
Sonderfonds der für die Bundeswehr
bereitgestellt wird auch im Grundgesetz
verankert da in den dass auch Geld nicht
zu was anderes ausgegeben wird das ist
ein Betrag und grundsätzlich erstmal in
die Bundeswehr also in Wien im
Materialien die wir dringend brauchen zu
investieren der Haushalt als solches ist
in der Tat in den letzten Jahren
gewachsen aber jetzt kommt die Frage das
ist eben nicht nur eine Frage des Geldes
ist sondern wir haben eine
wir haben das große Problem dass wir
mehr Geld haben aber deswegen haben wir
nicht ein oder auch nicht ein Flugzeug
mehr auf dem Boden sondern wir haben das
Problem dass mit der fachlichen
Beschaffung dieser Materialien so
unvorstellbar komplex ist so langwierig
ist dass wir eben das vor allen Dingen
auch in die Gänge bringen müssen also
Geld ist das eine 100 Milliarden dann
wächst der Wehretat die berühmten
Prozent vielleicht noch dahin gehen
etwas sagen das ist 2014 vereinbart
worden in der NATO als Russland die Krim
annektiert hat also in dem Moment wurde
das Weißbuch neu geschrieben das ist das
Buch was der Bundeswehr sagt was Ihre
Aufträge sind oder hieß es dass wir
wieder in die bündnis- und Landespartei
gegen zurückkehren was wir nach 1990
nämlich langsam abgebaut haben und in
diesem Augenblick war eben auch klar
dass wir mehr Mittel brauchen die sind
sollten diese zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes sein also je
reicher ein Land je mehr muss es
investieren und nun kommt eben die
Geschichte das hat Deutschland erstens
nicht gemacht und zweitens ist das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt natürlich ein sehr
weicher Faktor wir haben durch die
Pandemie so viel Geld ausgeben müssen
und dass das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
gesunken ist und der Wehretat wenn Sie
so wollen diese zwei Prozent sind näher
gerückt also rein rechnerisch aber auf
der Straße ist deswegen nicht mehr
gegangen also wir werden mit deutlich
mehr Geld brauchen das wird jetzt auf
den Weg gebracht aber die Beschaffung
das heißt auch die Struktur der
Bundeswehr muss parallel auch verändert
werden weil sonst werden wir diesen
Erfolg nicht erzielen können Herr
Sensburg wo muss das Geld ihrer Meinung
jetzt als erstes hin also zum einen
möchte ich noch mal Frau Strack
Zimmermann recht geben es ist jetzt
nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt über die
Wehrpflicht zu diskutieren der
Reservistenverband macht das auch nicht
jetzt sondern macht es ganz
grundsätzlich ob es aus verteidigungs-
und sicherheitspolitischer Notwendigkeit
heraus richtig und wichtig ist die
Wehrpflicht wieder einzuführen das ist
der eine Punkt jetzt sollten wir eher
darüber nachdenken das machen wir auch
wo können wir hilfeleisten wo sind zum
Beispiel Reservist und Reservisten
demnächst gebraucht wenn es viele
Flüchtlinge gibt wo können wir
unterstützen wenn es um die Sicherung
kritischer Infrastruktur geht wo können
wir unterstützen dass es unsere Aufgabe
wo wird das Geld gebraucht da würde mich
natürlich zum ersten interessieren die
100 Milliarden in dem davon wann werden
sie verausgabt über welchen Zeitraum
reden wir von zehn Jahren reden wir von
vier Jahren das ist ganz wesentlich weil
das zeigt auch ein bisschen die
Dimension es ist gut dass es ein
Sondervermögen ist das zeigt das Geld
kommt wirklich zur Bundeswehr es wird
bei der Bundeswehr ankommen das ist eine
richtige Entscheidung dass das auch im
Grundgesetz verankert wird und dann wird
die Frage sein wo genau wird das Geld
auch eingesetzt das wird natürlich in
die großen Rüstungsprojekte zum
einfließen müssen in einem moderne
Bundeswehr in eine leistungsfähige
Bundeswehr das wird auch bei den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten ankommen müssen
und es wird auch im Heimatschutz in der
Landesverteidigung ankommen müssen und
da sind es natürlich auch gerade
Liegenschaften da sind es aber auch die
Ausrüstungsgegenstände für die Reserve
das geht um Fahrzeuge es geht um Waffen
es geht im Endeffekt um die gesamte
Bundeswehr Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung steht im Vordergrund
steht im Fokus und da müssen die 100
Milliarden Euro auch wirklich in
eingesetzt werden
Frau Streik Zimmermann können Sie uns
das beantworten wann und wo wann soll
die 100 Milliarden eingesetzt werden wie
schnell geht das ja ich würde gerne
erstmal eine Lampe für die Reserve
brechen es ist auch so dass wir im
ampelvertrag im Koalitionsvertrag
explizit hervorgehoben haben oder ein
wichtigen Satz reingeschrieben haben
dass die Reserve gestärkt werden muss
und gerade im Kontext der Probleme die
wir haben wird die Rolle der Reserve
eine große Rolle spielen und die muss
natürlich dann auch entsprechend
ausgerüstet sein da bin ich völlig sind
wir völlig einer Meinung es geht
natürlich darum wir haben wenn ich so da
sagen darf eine Liste von Problemen die
gelöst werden müssen und es wird jetzt
daran liegen wie schnell man das Geld
umsetzen kann ich nehme mal wie lange
Diskussionen auch in der großen
Koalition der Tornado Nachfolge eines
Kampfflugzeuges was umgehend angegangen
werden muss natürlich werden diese
Flugzeuge wenn sie verkauft werden
stehen nicht morgen alle auf der Straße
oder besser gesagt auf dem Rollfeld
sondern die werden natürlich sukzessive
angeschafft insofern verteilt sich auch
die Ausgabe aber alles was wir
anschaffen werden ob das eine Frage der
der Boden luftparteidigung ist ob das
schwerer Transport mit Schrauber ist nur
mal um wenige Beispiele zu nennen das
müssen wir jetzt auf dem Markt kaufen
und ich glaube was ganz wichtig ist bei
der ganzen Frage dass wir in der
Beschaffung aufhören immer ein
explosives Modell selber kreieren zu
wollen das ist nämlich sehr deutsch dass
man einen bestimmten Hubschrauber will
nach bestimmten Maßstäben sondern die
Sachen von denen wir reden und die die
das Militär und die Bundeswehr brauchen
die gibt es bereits die gibt es von
europäischen Anbietern die gibt es von
amerikanischen Anbietern die Stellen die
Israelis her das heißt jetzt ist die
Stunde zu schauen was ist auf dem Markt
was können wir sehr zügig sehr schnell
beschaffen also das wird jetzt die große
Frage sein und meine Frage oder oder
meine Hoffnung ist auch und das hat die
Verteidigungsministerin auch der
Justizminister
wie gesagt das geht auch juristisch
geklärt bin geklärt wird den keine
Juristin dass es möglich ist auch direkt
zu vergeben also nicht diese
unvorstellbar langen Ausschreibung
sondern zu schauen was bietet der Markt
was brauchen wir oder anders was
brauchen wir priorisieren was bietet der
Markt und dann einkaufen und dann eben
sukzessive zuführen das wird
entscheidend sein und ein letztes die
persönliche Ausrüstung da hat ja
Sensburg völlig Recht die persönliche
Ausrüstung für jede Soldaten für jeden
Soldaten ist das A und O ich möchte
nicht mehr darüber debattieren dass
bestimmte Jacken fehlen das bestimmte
Wäsche fehlt vor allem möchte ich auch
nicht dass unsere Soldaten und Soldaten
die Auslandseinsatz sind das ist ja eine
zusätzliche Aufgabe die auch bleibt
sozusagen ihre ihre bestimmten Westen
die sie haben abgeben und die Kameraden
überlassen der dann im Zuge des
Austausches des kontingentsaustausches
beim Ziel ankommt es bedarf jeder nach
seiner Fähigkeit mit einer kompletten
Ausrüstung mit allem was es bedarf und
das ist dann auch persönlich und damit
anzufangen wäre schon eine große
Zimmermann da unterbreche ich sie auch
mal kurz wir haben noch so viele Themen
über die wir auch noch sprechen wollen
das passt aber auch das was sie gerade
sagen beantwortet eine Frage aus dem
Stream von Takko wird die Bundeswehr
jetzt kurzfristig mit den akut
benötigten Materialien Unterwäsche wird
hier genannt versorgt das hat frau
Zimmermann gerade beantwortet ja das
steht also auf der Liste wir wollen noch
mal ganz kurz in einen Ton reinschauen
und zwar gestern Abend war der ehemalige
Nato-General Egon Rams bei uns im
heute-journal hat sich auch zu dem Thema
geäußert wir hören mal kurz rein
wenn man vorhat neue Waffensysteme zu
kaufen bei NATO Partnern beispielsweise
bei den Amerikanern und diese
Waffensysteme sind fertig dann kann man
sie relativ schnell beschaffen ich nehme
als Beispiel dafür den schweren
Transporthubschrauber da stand man im
letzten Jahr vor einer Entscheidung die
Entscheidung ist nicht mehr getroffen
worden sie könnte jetzt sofort und
unverzüglich getroffen werden und dann
könnte man relativ schnell mit der
Auslieferung von der Stückzahl her würde
ich mal sagen drei bis vier Jahre dieses
Manko ersetzen die ca 53 Ausdauer
ein anderes Waffensystem welches heute
auch im Gespräch gewesen ist war die F35
vom Kanzler selber erwähnt das dürfte
nicht ganz so schnell gehen weil davon
keine Waffensysteme zurzeit verfügbar
sind und weil wenn wir die Waffensysteme
haben auch diese erstmal bei uns
eingeführt werden müssen und dann auch
die Piloten in Besatzung entsprechend
ausgebildet werden müssen
Frau streckt Zimmermann sie noch mal
dazu sofort und unverzüglich das nannte
jetzt Egon Rams als ja eine Maßnahme wie
man handeln müsste ist das realistisch
kommen wir jetzt in die Gänge kann das
sein dass wir jetzt auch mal sofort und
unverzüglich handeln
ja natürlich kommen wir jetzt in die
Gänge das ist die Aussage gestern und
ich freue mich möchte dass an dieser
Stelle auch sagen dass es eben zwischen
der Ampel und der CDU dass wir da
wirklich an einen Strang ziehen ich
glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig
schwerer Transporthubschrauber ja der
Markt gibt es genug und Sie müssen sich
vorstellen wenn man einige brauchten
kommen wirklich nicht alle gleichzeitig
das ist nicht so eine Familie Knopf die
zwei Autos möglicherweise und die Rollen
gleichzeitig alles ist das eine die F35
ist das modernste Kampfflugzeug der Welt
das muss in der Tat hergestellt werden
das kann sowohl den USA als in auch in
Europa hergestellt werden und auch ja
die Piloten müssen natürlich trainiert
werden aber das ist das normale der
Tornado um den ästhetischen Nachfolge um
den es geht der fliegt ja noch eine
Weile aber wir müssen es endlich angehen
wenn das Problem ist bekannt das Ende
der 20er der Tornado nicht mehr im
Einsatz sind auch was das Thema atomarer
Teilhabe betrifft und deswegen ist es
wirklich sowas von überfällig dass wir
es machen und das kann man sozusagen
angehen und man kann jetzt Verträge
unterschreiben und es jetzt angeht
das unsere Bundeswehr dürfte ich
ausgestattet ist das ist tatsächlich
kein Problem was jetzt plötzlich
aufgetaucht ist und Thomas gonsor hat
für uns mal zusammengefasst er seit wann
und vor allem was da so alles schief
gegangen ist in der Vergangenheit
bedingt abwehrbereit so die berühmte
Titelstory des SPIEGEL die Bundeswehr so
die Diagnose 1962 sei mangelhaft
ausgestattet
seitdem ist die Geschichte der deutschen
Streitkräfte auch eine von Pleiten Pech
und Pannen Beispiele der Eurofighter in
den 80er Jahren entwickelt 2003
ausgeliefert die Kampfflugzeuge hatten
technische Mängel konnten oft nicht
starten neue Corvetten etwa die
Oldenburg bei Probefahrten 2009 stellte
man Getriebeschäden Fest erst vier Jahre
später läuft sie aus
der Schützenpanzer Puma immer wieder
technikprobleme ein Panzer der auch
einfach mal ungeplant anhält Bedienung
kompliziert
Hauptsicherung
wo war die noch gleich zudem Ersatzteile
nicht lieferbar die Kosten für 350
Panzer verdoppelten sich auf mindestens
6 Milliarden Euro voller
Einsatzbereitschaft wohl erst 2030
letztes Beispiel der Kampfhubschrauber
Tiger entwickelt und gebaut in den 80ern
wegen technischer Mängel funktionsfähig
erst in den 2010er Jahren und politisch
umstritten denn das Konzept schien nach
dem Kalten Krieg veraltet gedacht war
der Tiger für Einsätze gegen sowjetische
Panzer denkbar nun im Kampf gegen Putins
Truppen
vor fünf Tagen war im heute-journal
Nato-General ad Rams zu Gast Frage ist
die Truppe jetzt abwehrbereit steht
aktuell natürlich auch nicht zu Debatte
das tatsächlich die Bundeswehr dieses
Land Deutschland verteidigen muss wäre
sie dazu in der Lage aktuell nein
klare Antwort nein
Herr Sensburg viele Jahre lang war das
Verteidigungsministerium in den Händen
von ihrer Partei der CDU warum ist da
eigentlich so wenig passiert in den
ganzen Jahren das ist ja jetzt wie
gesagt nicht erst ein Problem seit heute
seit gestern weil es ist viele Jahre zu
wenig passiert weil wir
gesamtgesellschaftlich die Meinung
hatten wir haben eine Friedensdividende
wir sind umgeben von Partnern von
Freunden es wird den großen Krieg die
große militärische Auseinandersetzung
nicht mehr geben und das ging nicht nur
uns in Deutschland so das ging auch in
vielen anderen EU-Staaten so wo die
Verteidigungsausgaben gesenkt worden
sind wo man weniger investiert hat wo
man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
konnte dass man eine Armee braucht dass
man Landesverteidigung noch nötig hat
und so haben wir lange Zeit ich will mal
sagen fast in einer Seifenblase gelebt
die jetzt geplatzt ist und wir erkannt
haben dass wir wieder Bündnis und
Landesverteidigung brauchen dass wir
wieder erheblich mehr in unsere
Sicherheit investieren müssen und das
ist richtig
wird in Waffensysteme in Ausrüstung
gehen müssen das wird nach meiner
Meinung aber auch in die Stärke der
Truppe gehen müssen also wie viel
Soldatinnen und Soldaten wir haben denn
irgendwer muss die Hubschrauber fliegen
muss die Flugzeuge bedienen muss im
Grunde auch die Panzer fahren und muss
auch gegebenenfalls in vertriebataillone
darstellen und da braucht es Soldatinnen
und Soldaten und deswegen müssen wir
auch darüber diskutieren wie groß die
Truppe sein wird in Zukunft denn das ist
auch klar wenn wir Waffensysteme
anschaffen ist eins der großen Probleme
in den letzten Jahren gewesen dass wir
kleine Stückzahlen haben das macht uns
sowohl bei den Verkäufern nicht gerade
zu einem starken Verhandlungspartner das
haben wir beispielsweise selbst bei
Airbus gesehen es führt aber auch dazu
dass wenn wir einzelne Ausfälle haben
wir sehr große Probleme haben die
Ausfälle zu ersetzen von daher die Größe
der Truppe spielt sowohl bei den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten bei der Zahl
eine Rolle aber natürlich auch hinter
bei der Ausrüstung bei der
Leistungsfähigkeit
wir haben gerade im Beitrag gesehen also
wie viele Pannen es da gab Frau
Zimmermann wie kann man denn
sicherstellen dass das Geld jetzt bei
der Bundeswehr dann einen guten Händen
ist für die Zukunft
naja eine ein solcher Kraftakt der jetzt
in die Wege geleitet wird heißt auch
immer enge Zusammenarbeit mit der
Industrie und natürlich sind wir kein
Großabnehmer mehr für die Industrie
schon lange nicht mehr also auch die
Industrie hat ihre Kapazitäten für
Deutschland in Deutschland radikal
runtergefahren aber und so viel Kritik
muss jetzt jeder ertragen sowohl die
Politik als auch die Herstellung das
nehme ich auch Material geliefert wurde
ich fand das übrigens gerade ziemlich
eindeutig der Film den die gezeigt haben
dass also die industriematerial und
liefert was eben nicht optimal ist
beziehungsweise auf der anderen Seite
selbstkritisch dass eben auch manche
Ersatzteile nicht mitbestellt worden
sind die man hätte vorab mit bestellen
müssen damit sie da sind wenn man sie
braucht das ist also keine Fahrrad wo
man was kaputt geht dann fährt man zu
jedem zum Fahrradhändler der schraubt
werden und das sind komplexe
Waffensysteme wo sie also die sensiblen
Teile schon vorweg Teil kaufen müssen
das wurde nicht gemacht weil dann wäre
ja der
das Geld noch schneller durch den Finger
gewonnen also da haben sich alle
Beteiligten wirklich nicht mit Ruhm
bekleckert und wenn wir jetzt diesen
Auftrag annehmen und wenn wir jetzt
diesen Weg gehen dann darf es eben
kleinen sein sondern dann muss die
Bundeswehr das Umsetzen dann muss die
Politik das entsprechend begleiten das
Geld muss ankommen die Industrie muss
liefern und zwar in Verantwortung nicht
nur in Menge und die Beschaffung darf
jetzt nicht von Bedenkenträgern hier
initiiert werden sondern das ist jetzt
ein gemeinsamer Akt der in die Wege
geleitet werden muss
ich will zum Ende dieser Sendung jetzt
doch noch mal auf das Thema Wehrpflicht
zurückkommen denn ich lese es in euren
Kommentaren ich habe es gesehen dass
euch das sehr beschäftigt und deswegen
wollen wir es jetzt doch noch mal
aufgreifen und ich würde gerne zum Ende
jetzt auch noch mal wissen und zwar ich
suche mir jetzt hier mal aus diesem
Wurst wirklich von Fragen einfach nur
ein paar raus und zwar
City Wings möchte gerne wissen wie soll
eine Wehrpflicht nach der Schließung
vieler Kasernen wieder aufgenommen
werden ich stelle mir die Umsetzung der
Ausbildung ziemlich schwierig vor die
Umsetzung der Ausbildung genau die Frage
an Sie ja Sensburg sie sind ja dafür für
die Wehrpflicht wie soll das gehen
erstmal ist glaube ich ganz wichtig dass
die Musterung stattfinden kann das ist
natürlich alles im Grunde abgeschafft
worden die ganze Struktur man muss sie
wieder aufbauen auch das wäre ein
Kraftakt der einen längeren Zeitraum
auch bedarf dann werden die Einheiten
die aktiven Einheiten die auch früher
Ausbildung gemacht haben wir hatten ja
bis 2011 die Wehrpflicht ausbilden
können und man muss sagen das Argument
von Frau Strack Zimmermann ist richtig
wir hatten keine wergerechtigkeit mehr
weil du ein teil Jahrgangs gemustert
wurde das hätten wir aber selbst in der
Hand gehabt zu sagen wir Mustern wieder
die ganzen Jahrgänge der Bedarf ist da
also es wäre eine große aufgabestruktur
wieder aufzubauen aber da reden wir
gerade drüber welche Struktur brauchen
wir welche Liegenschaften welche
modernen Liegenschaften brauchen wir die
werden wir auch für den Heimatschutz
gebrauchen und notwendig haben denn es
wird auch nicht so sein dass Reservistin
und Reservisten im Heimatschutz
eingesetzt werden können in Zukunft in
erheblich größerer Zahl wir reden von
100.000 reservistinnen und Reservisten
in Zukunft und übernachten dann alle im
Hotel also wir brauchen ohnehin
Strukturen erheblich mehr als bisher in
der Bundeswehr
und Frau streckt Zimmermann die Frage an
Sie von Renate Sauter fragt sich warum
gibt es keine allgemeine Bürgerpflicht
wahlweise bei der Bundeswehr oder im
sozialen Bereich
also mit der mit der Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht ist auch die diese
Alternative seinerzeit entfallen wobei
die Verbände das sehr gut kompensiert
haben es wird immer mal wieder über eine
sogenannte Bürgerpflicht diskutiert also
dass junge Männer und Frauen nach
Schulabschluss sozusagen den starte
dienen wir sehen das als Liberale und
als Freie Demokraten kritisch weil wir
der Meinung sind dass jeder für sich
selber entscheiden muss was er macht
entscheidend ist das ist ein
freiwilliges Angebot gibt und die ab
freiwillige Angebote gibt es man kann
auch jeder der meint er möchte das
machen hat die Gelegenheit das zu tun er
kann auch zur Bundeswehr gehen eine Zeit
lang das heißt diese Strukturen sind da
aber eine Pflicht dafür das werden wir
nicht mittragen
die allerletzte Frage tatsächlich die
würde ich doch aber auch noch mal an Sie
richten Frau Strack Zimmermann die finde
ich nämlich auch sehr spannend die ist
hier auch bei uns aus dem Stream Viktor
regis fragt sich wird es einen
sozialstaatsabbau geben wenn dabei
gleichzeitig die Schuldenbremse
eingehalten werden sollte denn das hat
ja die FDP versprochen ist das quasi zu
Lasten auch von anderen Projekten dann
die Frage ist natürlich liegt auf der
Hand ich kann Ihnen nur sagen das was
wir gerade erleben der Angriff auf
Freiheit und Sicherheit und Frieden das
heißt wir gerade erleben dass ein
russischer Präsident sogar Atomwaffen
bereit ist in die Hand zu nehmen das
bedeutet dass wir uns um die Sicherheit
und zwar nicht nur dieses Landes ist es
immer eine bündnisfrage die Bundeswehr
ist nie alleine unterwegs wir sind
eingebettet in Europa eingebettet in die
NATO eingebettet in die UN das heißt
wenn uns diese Sicherheit diese
Selbstverständlichkeit mit dem ihr Leben
in Frieden in Demokratie wenn uns das
ist etwas wert sein soll dann wird jeder
seinen Beitrag dazu leisten müssen das
gibt es nicht zu nullsummen Spiel das
ist gar keine Frage aber das wurde auch
gestern sehr deutlich vom Bundeskanzler
und übrigens auch für vom Finanzminister
Lindner gesagt dass wir diese Freiheit
dass das uns etwas kosten muss und wird
sagt Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann von
der FDP vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren genauso Patrick Sensburg von
der CDU vielen Dank gerne vielen Dank
wir haben es also gerade auch noch mal
gehört von Frau Strack Zimmermann und
wir wissen es natürlich alle das was auf
dem Spiel steht vor allem für die
Menschen in der Ukraine insbesondere in
diesem Moment natürlich ist die Freiheit
für Sie für die Ukraine und natürlich
aber auch die Freiheit hier in ganz
Europa wir hoffen wir konnten euch
einige der Fragen die jetzt uns hier in
Deutschland so weit weg allerdings
aktuell beschäftigen beantworten und
sind jederzeit wieder für euch live bis
dahin danke tschüss